welcome back to new rock stars with the
mcu starting to ramp things up with the
multiverse everybody and their mamas are
wondering when we are going to be
blessed with a live action adaptation of
the infamous house of m storyline from
the marvel comics but what if i told you
that multiverse of madness secretly left
the seeds for house of m right under our
very noses hmm i don't know why i did
that
it was a very weird thing for me to do
and that rumored scarlet witch solo
project could potentially lead us to a
magical land of mutants
how would you all feel about that this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going the road with me today is the
always incredible scarlet whitney van
landingham what's going on hi
i'm good how are you
i'm feeling great i'm doing good i'm
going rogue with my friends today and
also
one of the coolest blurred women you
will ever meet to just coolest women in
general it's jessica clemens what's
going on girl what's up [ __ ] they're
gang
i get that from women a lot uh it's it's
a it's a common reaction
my baby
and finally the amazingly talented dj
wooldridge who has a new comic book that
he wants to tell you guys about take it
away what i do oh my god i do hello
thank you all for having me if you
lovely people will head on over to
hellbentcomicbook.com
uh you can see the kickstarter for my
latest comic hellbent uh which is a
supernatural thriller the kickstarter is
over however you'll see a little button
that says pre-order now you click on
that it'll take you to the pre-order
store so if you missed the kickstarter
you can still grab the comic it is a
48-page comic filled with
uh demons and uh violence and uh uh uh
nudity and all the stuff it's from
mature audiences only it's from violence
and nudity
[Laughter]
i'll let you know if you if you missed
volume one you can pick up volume one at
the pre-order store and volume one has
all the demon dick you need it's all in
there oh god
you know that's what i'm here for
so so if you're like i'm like so
impressed that you wrote a whole ass you
wrote two whole ass comics i am so
impressed with you that's amazing
seriously congratulations this is so
[ __ ] cool i'm so happy for you so for
people hell bent yeah it's for people if
you're fans of uh something that's
killing the children sandman preacher
anything like that hellbentbook.com
[Applause]
um but let's talk about our first topic
of today which is you know not as cool
as demon dicks but i'll try to let's try
to keep up with
that first topic of today is going to be
talking about how earth 838 is secretly
the future house of m universe because
think about it guys all right with the
when we last left wanda in 838 she was
not doing great in her life she just
murdered the entire illuminati um
fantastic four reed richards um
professor x all of them completely dead
and so she is probably in a really bad
spot and she's worried about her kids
and like the state of her kids and if
her kids are okay i think that that
wanda much like you know how 838 doctor
strange he ruined his the person that he
possessed life her life is about to be
ruined and that the entirety of her
universe is going to be converted into
the house of m universe
what do you guys think about that wild
and rogue theory i try to be as
extra rogue for you jessica extra extra
row i like it
i like it i like it i like where it's
going i just need to hear how yeah how
um tell me okay i think that you know we
know that the one division scenario
happened for just that little town of
west view i think that her grief is
going to become so great because like
all of the entire world is going to be
on her because she killed the people
that helped stop fandoms the person that
they have a statue of doctor strange up
for so i think that juan is going to be
like extra vilified more so than like
our wanda probably because like the
entire world knows that she is a killer
like she they basically
saw her walk into this building and like
kill all these people essentially so
like i feel like her her grief might be
a little bit greater than what we've
ever seen wanda and she might actually
end up just
changing the entire universe by
unlocking that scarlet witch power
i don't know pulling things out of my
ass
so i have a question i have a couple
questions on that one
the impression i got from 838 is that
they they were all about that uh lying
life like saying like uh dr strange
actually was a good guy don't don't look
behind the curtain he didn't do anything
bad we didn't murder him
um and also how much time do you think
we'll be spending in 838 moving forward
i think the a38 is going to be like
since they gave it a number i feel like
they're going to be a major player in
the mcu especially because we know that
the incursions are coming to the mcu
which involve multiple universes
colliding together and like we're gonna
eventually i think like we're gonna
eventually see eight three eight and six
one six have a little have a bit of a
tiff um
and uh encouraging which would be really
fun but i think that for now like we're
very much seeing like this new other
universe player being introduced so that
but that's just me i mean like we might
not even see a38 again who knows but
like i have a feeling that uh they're
setting up a house of m scenario because
that wanda like it just felt like
her story was sort of just left dangling
it's like my boys and she runs away it's
like what's what's what's going on with
her what's she seems like she's like
more things are going to happen with her
realistically
realistically i think that wanda was
probably now so traumatized and shook
that she doesn't even want to like
encourage her powers she's probably like
i if that's me in another timeline i
don't want to be like that but what i
like about your rogue theory is i have
this theory that i keep talking about on
the break room how the mutants when
kevin feige was like mutants everyone
was like x-men and he was like no i'm
not giving you x-men i'm just giving you
mutants uh i think that would be great
for it would be horrible for the
audience kill all the x-men in that
universe she gets rich she says no more
mutants in that universe gets rid of all
those x-men that way in 616 we still
have kamala and we still have um
monica who i'm sure is also a mutant uh
who are normal mutants in that timeline
but it would be disastrous for the
audience i know people would be so mad
how dare you kill jubilee
but
and i want that word
hater
i don't understand it i'm watching the
animated i'm re-watching the animated
series right now and i'm like okay i get
why she's the the full circle of it but
also she is the starlight like it's
unnecessary
like it's i just think that like i was a
kid obviously we were kids when we were
watching and she was like the the intro
characters like yeah she's like who i
projected myself onto because like i
like video games and i have a kid yeah
and i also like wolverine
jubilee or a shadow cat or a rogue there
you always have your like i love rogue
rogue is dope yeah yeah the country
voice sorry didn't mean to just didn't
mean to go off of the subject but i do
like yours oh no i'm feeling we had to
address the jubilee hatred you jubilee
phobic i see you
don't you dare take don't you tape my
name like that how dare you i don't want
these fans coming at me as a jewelry or
a julie a jubilee phobe
a true believer a jubilee that just that
just sounds like you hate being happy
yeah which i do
don't get it wrong don't get it down
like feeling i don't like it
[ __ ] out of here
i will say to your theory though i do
think if you know because there's talks
of like a scarlet witch movie or
whatever i do think it's gonna be eight
three eight one that is the scarlet i i
i was always on something she's gonna
find her way back to our world
but i figured that was kind of
the direction we were heading
to get like sorry sorry
you're done yeah that's a i love that
idea of like 838 wonder of wanting like
sort of revenge against 616 wanda for
ruining her life because i would want
revenge in some way i would i would
definitely go to 616 to have a chat at
least with one i'd be like um
can you tell people that it was you like
why you assumed that they would the
people higher up well i guess they're
all dead except for mordo but like you'd
assume they'd be like it wasn't this
wanda clearly it was wanda
going into their mind but i guess maybe
they're like it's easier to prosecute
this one that's already here
right it's just sad but it's i
understand the whole magic gobbledygook
it's just a master
i guess that like mordo could still
technically like report back but yeah
it's like everyone else is [ __ ] dead
so yeah yeah
who's gonna tell who's gonna tell him
guys who's gonna tomorrow's gonna be
like take that that single mother of two
and locker
honestly because like we know that mordo
has no love for anybody who has anything
to do with the dark hold whatsoever he's
just like i don't care what you have to
say you're gonna be locked up or you're
like i don't care so like i feel like
that's sort of very likely for mordo
just to not listen to her at all true
yeah okay well all right honestly this
would be kind of cool because i i had a
theory that i did a video on like a
while back whenever the movie came out
that i
thought that it's possible that you know
like the big like red flash at the end
when wunderguard collapses i was like
well maybe that was like wanda's powers
protecting her in some way um and so
maybe she's still alive because like
kind of something similar happens in
house of m where she's like no more
mutants and then she just loses all of
her memories but she's still
alive and then they have to like get her
and tell her oh you're the scarlet witch
so like i was thinking that baby
you know that's how that's how the
comics just go forever that's exactly
what it is that's pretty much it yeah no
you pretty much
description of house of m you know
so
so yeah i was wondering too if like if
maybe 616 wanda is still alive and she
is displaced i do think it would be
really [ __ ] cool to see 838 wanda be
like oh [ __ ] you're still alive i'm
kidding ya i'm gonna come get you you
ruined everything for me
yeah they definitely left a lot of a lot
of like doors open for themselves
because we've already introduced another
wanda and also you know in superior
movies if rubble falls on somebody it's
like well
they can come back i mean that's not
yeah i didn't see a box
exactly exactly i don't trust an
off-screen death i never trust one
seriously and like we know that marvel
studios especially when it comes to
their you know their big like main
avengers they like a good send-off for
their character they're not gonna kill
one of their main avengers off-screen so
like exactly yeah come on
she deserves a little tony stark funeral
pyre give give her that at least if
she's really dead exactly
exactly i mean i would prefer for her to
like destroy the universe before she
died but you know
i'll take whatever yeah you can't win
them all right
did you all did you all ever uh uh rogue
theory on who eight three eights wanda's
the dad is for wanda's kids did you ever
wrote who the dad is for those kids
ooh that's the second road question
[Laughter]
because i i have a theory i have a
theory on who the dad is for those kids
who is it who's the daddy i think it's
quicksilver
oh
my
if you've ever read if you ever read
this if you ever read the ultimate
comics wanda and quicksilver were a bit
closer in that universe they're so cool
i'm actually reading the ultimate x-men
like right now
it is so creepy how close they are it's
a little disturbing i'm not saying i
like it i'm just saying i'm just saying
think about little what the what the
little you guys little speed kid where
did it go where did power come
boys you from that weird [ __ ] to the
boys and leave our good named wanda
take that [ __ ] to the
boys on amazon.com
i just thought she was like a cool
divorcee like i thought she was just
like i'm a sexy independent wanda and
vision and i got a divorce because he
cheated on me with his secretary in cabo
you know like that's what i kind of
thought right
that enters another problem is like if
it is vision so then we have another
vision rolling and then it really
because i just i just rewatched infinity
war
and it's like
we we sacrificed how many wakandans
for a robot guy that we brought back we
just brought back in an afternoon like
you know what i mean and it's like so if
if there's another vision running around
it just makes that whole thing even more
pointless it just makes that whole
exercise and so it's like if there's
another vision
capsule like we don't trade lives except
for all these african lives we'll trade
those oh
jesus is coming in
but this robot this robot that we kind
of don't know how his consciousness work
that life no that's sacred we don't want
to mess with that one matters that one
really matters it'll make wanda sad and
we don't
we don't want that we don't want that
okay but like to be fair making wanda
sad is extremely dangerous it does turn
out it turns out that it's really bad i
wouldn't recommend it
it turns out the one
it's like not a cool thing
yeah massive body count when wanda gets
sad but anyway okay so for this the wild
theory about you know a38 becoming the
house of m how likely do you guys feel
like this is going to happen do you feel
like it's it's rogus bogus or the middle
ogus bro i think it's rogus i'm into it
i'm really into this theory i want to
see house of them happen i think it
would be so cool if it
was 838 wanda especially if like i said
she was on a little vengeance mission
against six one six wanda i dude that
would be so cool i hope i hope you're so
sick i would love it you're right i'm
gonna give you a rogues
[Music]
all right what do you think jessica
i
i'm also giving you a rogues i think you
did a good job
i think this was very wrong i did it
i think it was very good i will
never give him a rogue
okay
this is a very a very limited dish rogan
i will never forget this rogus for as
long as i live thank you listen i'm just
gonna make sense and i think it's fun
yeah i think i'm gonna keep the train go
go and i'll give you a rogus as well
let's let's give it let's give it a
clean sweep why not try to do it rogue
is dead
thank you i think that like this would
be really fun and especially if like 83
were to turn into the house of m
universe and then
collide with 616 for an amazing avengers
versus x-men scenario i would love it it
would be really dope um like i would i
would literally cry in my seat at the
theater
into my popcorn making it even more
saltier
thus threatening my blood pressure even
more
um
but up next we are going to talk about a
weird theory about the corpse of doctor
strange that was left behind on mount
wondergore but first don't forget to
check out our awesome merch options
available at
newrockstarsmerch.com because right now
you can grab our latest obsession shirt
inspired by thor love and thunder called
worthy of love and this shirt is limited
edition and won't be available for long
so be sure to grab it while you can i
mean you can support the channel by
checking out all of our amazing and
awesome merch over at
erockstarsmerch.com anytime but we want
to thank upstart for sponsoring this
episode of rogue theory it can be hard
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel especially when you have bad eyes
like me and high interest debt and
sometimes it can be even harder to ask
for help that's where upstart comes in
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple easy to understand
payment terms upstart has helped over
1.8 million customers on their path to
financial freedom so whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit score
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate in
minutes for loans between 1000 to 50 000
without impacting your credit score
amazing you can even receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan so do not wait and check your
rate today at upstart.com rogue theory
that is upstart.com rogue theory check
your rate today and don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and other
certain information provided in your
loan application go to upstart.com rogue
theory and we also want to thank upside
for sponsoring this video because
whether you're being absolutely stunned
when you fill up your car at the gas
station or have noticed the price of a
burrito at your favorite restaurant has
you know started to creep up and up one
thing is clear inflation is hitting us
where it hurts the wallet it hurts
really bad please stop inflating um it
and it really hurts and that's why many
of us here at new rockstars have started
using upside upside is an incredible app
for anyone who buys gas groceries or
dines out because with every purchase
you earn cash back thanks to upside to
get started download the free upside app
in the app store or google play use our
promo code rogue theory and get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more and next
claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit card
or debit card and then just get paid
it's pretty great um in comparison to
credit card rewards or loyalty programs
you earn three times more cash back with
upside you can cash out any time to your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands upside users
are earning more than a million dollars
every week and that's probably why they
have a 4.8 star rating on the app store
oscar producer brandon uses upside all
the time it's the best way to find a
place to eat on a friday night and all
you have to do is search for a
restaurant that you like that also has a
reward offer it's a literally a win-win
it's such a good app to download the
free upside app and use promo code rogue
theory to get five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
10 or more using promo code rogue theory
all right guys i think for the second
topic i think that marvel zombies are
coming to the mcu specifically in a very
sneaky way that they set up at the very
end of multiverse of madness because if
you remember if you remember
corpse doctor strange is still
under the rubble of wonder gore and
people just assume oh yeah just because
doctor strange like left the body
stopped possessing the body that
everything's fine incorrect because that
body is filled with all those souls of
the dance still inside of the body and i
believe that marvel studios is setting
that up to be the mcu version of a
marvel villain for doctor strange called
mr misery who is like this really gross
gnarly dude with a bunch of souls of the
damned in his body i feel like it just
makes a lot of sense and so with that
and since we know that this type of
magic that doctor strange use on his
corpse is a type of sort of like
necromancy i think
that this
being this
potential mr misery could be the
catalyst for marvel zombies coming to
the mcu by just resurrecting the dead by
just filling them with the souls of the
damned um and then just being just
starting things that way it'd be really
fun
what do you guys think that is so cool
oh my god i didn't even i didn't even
think about how it's still full of
damned little souls all those damn souls
gotta go somewhere why are you so smart
look at you
look at you
i dude i didn't even think about it like
that i just got a weird rogue theories
up in this cranium i just uh looked up
mr misery and he is a he's a he's a
looker let's put it that way he's a
looker he's looking i want to look at my
plate
he's struggling on bumble right now but
uh he'll go get that one he'll figure it
out
he'll unlock that secret how do you
think that connects to the um the we're
getting our marvel zombies animated
series right that's part of the mcu hmm
this is true i i feel like um because we
know from that episode of what if that
they described this uh zombie outbreak
as an encephalopathy i cannot believe i
said that word right the first time my
god i will not be able to do it again um
and so like it's sort of looks like a um
a brain infection i forget what uh it's
just like a weird thing like i feel like
they can science it away and just be
like yeah what's happening here is mr
misery is just infecting people's brains
like uh and like taking them over with
darkness and like you know and just i
don't know i started just copying that
what what they did with um and what if
and like adjusting it in the irl mcu
universe
i don't know
i'm here for this i'm i'm gonna
you haven't asked yet but i'm giving
this an early rogue because i am an
early rogue oh this is an early mountain
a preemptive rogue
yeah oh yeah what do you think jessica
it's serving kill grave it's giving kill
grave
and i want something different explain
to me okay so explain to me again so
we're saying that
he's collecting the souls in hell right
now correct
is that what you were saying
repeat your role no i'm saying that like
um this like corpse doctor strange that
that's trapped under wonder gore is
filled with the souls of the damned and
like this sold like this new being
that's what was created at the end of
multiverse of madness is going to go out
and start creating like start raising
the dead basically just going up to like
tombstones and just like
controlling the dead and like starting a
zombie army okay doctor strange zombie
wood or the mr which we call it so like
the so like the the corpse doctor
strange that is like under the rubble of
wonder gore i think that's going to
become mr misery mr misery is going to
start raising the dead oh
i think it's fine
i think it's fun okay and where do you
see
jessica is my barometer
and what uh in what movie what do you
see him coming in just in on his own
mark that's how marvel zombies will be
is that how you i think that doctor
strange three could be like the catalyst
there because like we know that that
movie is likely going to be very dark
because we see them going to the dark
dimension to face dormammu so i feel
like this is when like like that this
will probably be the catalyst for like a
midnight sun scenario because we know
that in every mcu movie we have to have
an army of easily killable people if the
tatari the ultron bots like they have to
be just like we need to be able to just
murder these people
[Laughter]
so what you're describing is almost like
a blackest night scenario where we're
like bringing back maybe you've got a
zombie army but also maybe bringing back
some dead folks from previous movies
exactly like you're pietros and like
maybe you're tony starks like people
that have died before like
it i feel like there's a lot of people
that we could just bring back but just
have died like killmonger but they'll be
zombies even though i feel like kill
blockers coming back in general i feel
like dumb mongers
i feel like they they're making a
mistake if they're not if they're not
just like retconning out that like the
end of black panther and making
killmonger the new black panther like
it's michael b jordan like come on
it would be super cool to see like a
better like a reformed killmonger like
being given the new black panther
that'll be really dope but i can
definitely see t'challa saving
killmonger at the end of that because
like he's not gonna he's too
compassionate yeah he'd be like great
great speech probably
we're going to a con in prison
yeah we're going to the hospital dude
yeah dude yeah that was cool that was a
really good thing but it's really
meaningful like it was really impactful
become unconscious
yeah like as soon as you become
unconscious i'm taking you to the
hospital you know right right
especially since he's the last one he's
the last one that ate the
the heart shaped with heart-shaped fruit
is that what it's called the that makes
you black panther the heart
shaper thank you and and so and then he
burned it all so technically
we can recon this way but technically
there shouldn't be anybody else that
could become black panther anyway well
is it and the series doesn't don't they
come up with like a mock version of the
heart-shaped herb so yeah and they could
just find more you know i mean like
there's easy ways that you could pick
yeah it turns out there's more and it's
like okay cool we're just moving on i'm
just i'm just saying from a practical
perspective
you you've unfortunately tragically have
are missing a lead and there's very few
uh leading men better than michael b
jordan and he's right there and so maybe
maybe i would love him
i think his mission his mission would
still be intentionally bad i think the
mission of like no we should give all i
think giving they were like yeah let's
give it to the people
of everywhere let's share our wealth but
i think he'd be like well
not with white people like he would be
like
so i think his intentions would still be
like that yes
no like it would still be and that's
where i think they couldn't be like
black panther is still pretty racist
my father does not like white people
even though this accidentally turned
into a black panther conversation
i think that they should go to like they
should uh go the tachaka room because
like we saw that chachaka was a black
panther at the very beginning of the
movie so if they got that actor back and
like did some weird time travel wormhole
whatever it's like all right i'm back as
black panther for a little bit before
they transition into
uh uh probably most likely a new
t'challa variant via the multiverse
during the whole secret wars thing like
we're gonna get a new t'challa like
that's
i feel like that's like inevitable just
give it to okay
just give it boy i said just give it to
a question
the number one statement
she's the most qualified that's most
reasonable
yeah my vote my vote outside of just
bringing killmonger back would be nakia
i think i think she of the because i
know um
um latisha wright's character shuri in
the comics becomes black panther but the
way they establish her character in the
movie doesn't feel like she'd be down it
doesn't feel like she'd be into being
black panther right
yeah but i do think though that if
anyone can figure out how to make like
this synthetic heart-shaped herb it
would be sherry yeah she would be the
one who would be able to engineer that
so maybe if she doesn't become black
panther she's just the one who helps
engineer the new black panther and helps
like make him
i don't know what's gonna happen you
guys we don't even have a trailer for
this movie
to go back to mt's point like i think we
are building towards you know maybe
bringing back people from the dead i
actually think that's where uh that's
specifically what the valhalla bit at
the end of um spoilers for love and
thunder is it's like i have a feeling
before i have a feeling thor five will
be thor valhalla and we're bringing back
odin and renee russo as the mom
and all that stuff don't think so
no i think it was more so just i think
it was just so it's like it's not on a
complete sad note that they were like no
see she's having fun she's involved it's
just that it's interesting that she is
it's just cancer but now she's having a
really good time she's great she's great
you should listen what kind of cancer
she had stage four don't ask questions
uh no that was the that was
just stage four in general yeah that was
the movie's last bit of hey guess what
these movies don't have any stakes
bye-bye
because i was like i was like i don't
think they would have because i don't
think they're gonna bring heimdall back
either i think it was just like a full
circle for his we saw his son we saw
axel we saw actually and so i think that
ending was just more so like see axel
had a great father and his great father
is now living in a great beyond oh i do
not want to see open again
[Music]
should just be the nice like this is
heaven they're going to be chilling in
heaven and we're not going to see them
again
because they want to show
and he's like welcome jane and she's
like
oh i'm i'm baptist i don't
[Music]
[Applause]
and battle every day and that's your
afterlife now okay
that is what you chose the last 20 days
of your life and that's what you're
gonna live in eternity doing
but i feel like jesus in his army is
gonna come battle valhalla it's going to
be this whole thing that's going to be
the next thor
jesus is the big bad of 4 or 5.
jesus
but it would be really funny to see him
to see jesus and thor go toe-to-toe
because jesus can turn water into wine
and thor can drink a whole bunch so i
think that that would be a really fun
drinking contest to see go down it's
just thor versus jesus who can trust
and you all saw the but you also saw the
concept art that russell crowe was
originally supposed to be the devil and
thor love him yeah right see so that was
wild that's what i was i would have
really dug
it just now occurred to me that i was
like oh yeah mephisto that's other
that's what
they wouldn't do that it's like well you
can't have the devil we have a guy his
name's mephisto it's like it's a dude
like you can't
he's the devil of the other you can't
just be russell crowe doing a weird
accent it's got to be it's going to be a
thing everybody wants them to show up
we're not going to do it
and if they don't put mephisto in eric
might actually die soon so we need we
need me to keep eric on life support
because i'm i'm worried about that guy
if we don't if we don't get it i
actually have a very rogue theory about
mephisto already being in the end i
actually think that uh strange supreme
is going to be mephisto um
i i honestly think i honestly think that
disney will not allow mephisto i think
they're they're worried to to get all
the christians mad at them and so
they're never going to do the devil
just like little five-year-olds dressed
as mephisto running around disneyland
i just have this i just have this
feeling disney standards and practices
will not let mephisto get out the gate
that's my that's my rogue theory
i wonder this is why i think that like
this is why i think strange supreme is
mephisto because like i feel like if
they show people that this mephisto
isn't actually the actual devil and that
like we should show the origin story of
the devil it's like oh that's just
doctor strange who just got really bad
yeah yeah
so like you you identify it less than
with like the actual christian devil
wasn't that kind of one of the theories
going around with loki is that uh
mephisto's just a loki variant don't
think too hard about it uh you know what
i mean
it didn't end up being that way it
didn't end up being that way i just feel
like that's what people were saying
did you guys see that i dressed up
pugsley as mephisto for this past
halloween what if
pugsley is i think that pugs leaked
might actually i think that was that was
my first guess
what's coming to the mcu is that he's
just gonna show up and be like uh hi
everybody uh welcome to the mcu my name
is parsley adams i'm a very good boy and
uh today i'm gonna i'm gonna drag you
all to hell with me come on
come to hell everybody come to hell
everybody
they got tons of snacks down there i
made sure of it
that's pretty chill sounds pretty chill
all right all right so the actual
question of this strange corpse becoming
the catalyst of this new zombie outbreak
um what do you guys think rogus bogus or
ogus you got that early i'll get there
the early rogue is from me baby
[Music]
what do you think dj
i'm gonna i'm gonna hit hit ogus i like
this the idea of mr mr misery showing up
i like the idea of mr misery showing up
but i don't i i kind of feel like we're
done with dead doctor strength i feel
like that would
but they i've just done i think it's
just a corpse at the bottom of a bunch
of rubble
a bunch of rocks like finally buried
yeah yeah yeah done he's done although
although i just i can't i can't leave
this conversation without me saying that
that is i love that scene in the movie
where he possesses his own corpse and
flies in on a cape of the right it's
amazing super cool it's amazing so cool
baby
oh my god all those arms all right jess
what do you think rogus bogus orogis i
agree with dj when i'm like i think
we're done with dead doctor strange
but i don't disagree and i think
what i don't like about them to use they
take your favorite freaking characters
for one movie and then whisk them away
and taskmaster uh so i think
we we can get in this forever me and umt
but i think
uh mr misery is a great
addition i think mr misery be a great
point to grab from for the writers i
think no one would really know him that
well they'd have to look him up so i
think it would be 100 i've never heard
of that guy till today
and he's scary and very fun so do i
think he's gonna show up in doctor
strange no no no no no but will he show
up in another dark sinister marvel movie
that we're eventually gonna get to i
completely think i could agree with and
it's so rogue that i think it is rogus
and wow i'm gonna give it i gave you two
holy [ __ ] two rogues that is fantastic
is this a record i'm i'm going to turn
into a pretty butterfly i feel like i'm
i'm i've trimmed i feel so happy on the
inside it's a good character if you
pulled a a shitty character i would have
given you a bogus but that character
a good character good gripe
um
[Laughter]
anyway but all right guys now it is time
for our rogue question you guys ready
for this one hell yeah so the extra
rogue here because with comic-con
happening right now as we speak what
would be your rogues cosplay option for
comic-con this year you know what i've
been seeing i saw one kid do it and i
really want to do it
um
the deep from the boys but with the
awkwardness on his jokes
as soon as i saw it i was like damn i
wish i was creative enough to grab such
weird scenes i just grabbed the
character i don't think about the one
scene that was 30 seconds
horrible
but yeah i would try to do that how
about you guys i'm sure you got
something good whitney what you got what
do you got so wait this is supposed to
be like the
dopest uh cosplay the craziest cosplay
that you would wear crazy possible or
like the rogus or any cosplay that you
would wear
rogue cosplay you would wear
well see for me for me when i do when i
uh i don't really cosplay but whenever i
think about it it's always got
comfortability accessibility you know
what i mean um so i always like like
just just mention the boys you know
butcher from the boys easy
that's super comfy yeah i guess you
could try to do that accent the entire
time yeah yeah yeah probably not that
but the uh
um the other one i always wanted to do
um is uh is the mr knight i always
thought that looked uh it's very very
slick such a dope suit uh it looks cool
i didn't really love how they did the
character in the show but the suit
always looked cool
all right all right i dig it mister i
can see you in a nice mr night costume
i'm
sick man i dig it i'm into that i really
like you okay my answer is a joke that i
already made to dj on his podcast
like last week but i'm not joking i
strongly want to dress up as vechna in a
cheerleader costume because
during mt i'm sorry you're not caught up
on stranger things but
vecna kills them
yeah he kills head cheerleader chrissy
cunningham and later on dr brenner
explains that when vekna kills somebody
he
takes everything that they are including
all their talent skills attributes
powers that's how he gets stronger and
so he has the powers of chrissy
cunningham hawkins high cheerleader and
so i would really like to do
vecna in a cheer costume pom-poms all
the way baby hitting hitting those
herkies hitting that hitting the top of
that pyramid i'm into it i want to do
that so bad and i'm sorry dj that i'm
telling you the same joke twice but i
mean that's how serious i am about it
yeah it's perfect and i also think it it
it uh
correctly answers the question because
that is a very rogue cosplay like it's
it's in the spirit of the question
that's what i'm trying to say yeah
exactly in the spirit of the question
these are all great answers these are
all really great rogue cosplays i would
love to see all of you guys in these
cosplays but like i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna have to give it to whitney for
that one because like that is a super
mega road i would have never considered
seeing a monster in a cheerleader outfit
um because maybe outside technically has
all of her powers he's got that means
he's got it
it's like bring it on vecna edition i
love it i love it when you mention it
because i love i love the concept of
like getting somebody's powers in a
universe where no nobody but you has
power you're it guy no look who what
powers are you taking like come on man
[Laughter]
exactly but that is it for this episode
of rogue theory a huge thank you to our
amazing guests jessica clemens dj
woodridge and brittany van landingham be
sure to follow them wherever they are on
on the internets and of course be sure
to hit up
hellbentcomic.com to pick up hellbent
like today because it's an amazing comic
and dj is a wonderful wonderful writer
and man in general thank you for coming
on the show we love having you yeah
thank you for having me hellbent
comicbook.com yeah thank you oh
hellbookcomicbook.com yeah make sure you
get that book in there i might take you
to the wrong place
[Music]
and of course you can support our
channel by checking out all of our
amazing merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you got
some rogue theories of your own you can
share them on our discord just make sure
you are 18 years old and older you can
just search for us on discord or you can
just click the link in the description
to join the conversation today you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
you can follow the new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet and
thank you guys we love you guys so much
for spending time with us we'll see you
guys next time bye
[Music]
you